this game was played in 1985 between
Wilhelm Steinitz the world the first
world champion and the Curt forum bottle
label and if you search for this game
online you will find it under the name
of develop Hastings but the first time I
saw this game was in some book about old
masters and the author named this game
the bravest rook in jazz history and
this is the name I prefer and the
Swingle CY
Jose raúl capablanca said about this
game that it was one of the last
masterpieces of the old age so let's see
the game silence is white and combat 11
is black d4 d5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to c4 be sure to c5 detailing
again c3 Knight to f6 d 4e takes b4 c4
and I wish would be for check Knight to
c3 and if black would stay sunny for
here we would go into the main line of
the Greco attack but butter lady knows
better and he plays v5 e takes d5 United
States and d5 and here
Chinese castle and blacks can't really
win a pawn here because if he goes nice
takes c3 be 63 Bishop takes c3 attacking
the rook simply Bishop to a3 locking the
black King in the center of the board is
a lot better for white and if for
example Bishop takes c3 be tc39 takes c3
then Queen before is crushing as I can
guess them and also attacking the knight
on c3 so here
Bartoli plays Bishop to e6 and here
shiny develops Bishop to g5 attacking
the Queen Bishop back to b7 and here
steinitz forces a series of trade to
improve his position Bishop takes on b5
Bishop takes on d5 nice takes on b5
Queen take 75 and I'll take sunny Sun
nice space 77 and rook
one and here we can see that black king
is stuck in the middle of the board and
for the time being he can't cancel and
black tried f7 he will try to Blake in
place the Kings f7 and Castle
artificially Queen to e2 threatening
checkmate on e7 Queen to d7 defending
and here tiny place group the c1 a very
very sneaky me this was played a couple
of months after each tiny quality of the
World Championship title to Emmanuel
aster and everybody thought that the old
master was ready to retire and that well
throughout his entire chest rarity she
came who weren't a very imaginative so
instead of brooding when he played route
to see one here and here
Bart eleven probably should have went
for King f7 and trying to get his King
to safety
instead he plays pawn to c6 maybe
thought that they came to f7 then Queen
to see for withholding some problems as
he attacked the c7 point but Knight to
d5 probably holds all of this but
nevertheless he played he said and this
is where Stanek proved everyone wrong
and shows his imagination like going to
d5 and this is very troublesome for
black if he allows white to get from c6
white will have the the D file open and
this will be crushing and black can't
really capture the pawn with nice as
it's been the she can't move the Queen
because of the may come Pisa so the only
thing he really has on day 25 and here
shine it shows why the pawn sacrifice is
good keep ropes is my position nice to
d4 and is preparing nice the e6 into s7
finally and the Chinese plays Knight to
e6 and this night becomes a monster
and here Bartel it in place rook HTTP
finally bringing the broke into the game
but as you'll see it's far too late for
that
Queen to g4 threatening on g7 and black
has descended somehow and the Bardot
Laden price pawns GG 6 and here is the
start of a beautiful combination nice to
g5 checks pinning the Queen and the as a
knight cannot be captured the only way
to defend the queen is a came back to EA
to the starting position and this is why
I prefer the name the bravest looking
chest history as Chinese place roof
takes on e7 check and this is a this is
quite crushing as the rook cannot be
taken for example if the Queen takes the
rook
then simply rook takes on c8 and this is
me rogue has to capture Queen Esther the
Queen captures Weiss is simply a piece
of and there is no defense for example
with the da Queen captures here the King
captures and Knight f3 is simply upper
piece so after roughly soundcheck even
the Kings cannot capture the route as we
have to follow me why Queen to b4 check
and here Kings has to go to eh rook to
e1 check and this is crushing team to d8
and 96 and the King has no squares nice
has to be taken and simply rip takes
Queen and there is no more back rank
mate because Dirk will simply go back to
e1 so after rook to e7 something has to
be played here so Bart 11 plate into s 8
and here this brave route continues his
journey place route to f7 check and the
rook again cannot be taken because of
the same line
King to g8 and the rook goes on to rip
the GSM check again the work cannot be
taken because black loses too much pink
to a chase and here strannix plays rook
takes on h7 check and this is actually
when who were from Barbie Laden he
didn't resign he just left the playing
hall and this is something he was not to
do quite often he didn't resign the
games he just left and he waited for his
time to run out and later this this type
of behavior was called to pull a bar
later so then he said to wait for his
time to run out and after the time run
out this is the line he showed to the
reporters so the King has to go back
King to g8 and now the rock follows him
rook continues his young route to g7
check and here if King goes to si simply
nice to a7 check win straight away if
King to d8 then Queen takes and
disseminate and this King takes the rope
then simply queen take some d7 winning
both works also crushing so the only
move is King back to a chase but the
problem here is that the H file is open
and now we have this Queen h4 check
forcing the team to take the rook so we
have King takes this very broken g7 we
have Quinto ate some check in Class
eight Queen the HS check only move came
to the seven Queen to g7 check King to
EA we have Queen to GA check it has to
go back to be seven now we have Queen f7
check here we have came to d8 and we
have Queen sa check the Queen has to
block winter EA here we have a nice to
f7 check the Kings has to go to the
seven only move and this
very nice into the six
checkmate so yeah that's the game like I
said it was played a couple of months
after China closes the World
Championship title - Emmanuel Astor and
- he was eager to show everyone that she
still has what it takes to play HS and
as he did he played this game that went
down in history by the name of her
fidelity things by the place where it
was played in Hastings England but I
think the bravest broken chess history
is a much better name for this game so
thank you for watching and I hope you
enjoyed it and see you soon